all
right good morning
everyone um and welcome to the special
committee on the covid
response um I would like to open the
meeting and I would ask representative
Merchant to lead us in the pledge if he
would thank
you I'm not going to read the ENT High
mission statement but I would just want
everyone to understand that this
committee is about finding facts on the
covid response through scientific uh
data so
[Music]
um we have in the audience uh uh miss
Patricia Tilly
from
DHHS and uh she is going to go over the
timeline with us um and explain to us
how things rolled out uh for the State
of New
Hampshire and I truly appreciate her
being here so thank you very
much
y
good morning um for the record again my
name is Patricia Tilly I am an associate
commissioner at the Department of Health
and Human Services thank you so much for
inviting me to be here today to go
through the timeline of events uh for
the covid-19 pandemic my review today
will simply be uh based in facts and
dates and events much like your mission
it's not a full after Action Report with
recommendations we're just going to go
through the wayb back machine and go
through time um we're going to set the
stage for what happened when in front of
you as I said is a draft document it
looks a little bit like the children's
game shoots in ladders you're going to
have to follow along as we go forward it
takes you on a three-year Journey from
January 2020 to the end of the federal
Public Health Emergency in May
2023 again importantly this is a draft
document all of us lived those years
together it impacted every part of our
Lives um and later this morning or on
further reflection I would I need from
you if possible um feedback as to
whether there are important moments you
feel are missing or that should also be
captured in such a document this was an
opportunity for my staff and I to go
back through some documents and sort of
just lay out you know what happened when
it is additive to the after action
report that I talked about last time we
gathered that Homeland Security is
developing that is a much more
comprehensive document this simply is
just sort of the timeline of things
today so uh while I'm not prepared today
to do that full reflection or after
action review I do have some thoughts to
frame this journey that we're about to
take together number one communication
is the response we all felt um at times
with the changing evolving and confusing
messages we felt unmowed at times we
overused the word unprecedented because
this crisis was exactly that but
transparency is key and part of that
transparency is communicating when
things change and we there are many
lessons to be learned about the way
things were communicated to the public
about the ways in which Comm State agen
genes communicated with each other the
way the federal government communicated
with the state department tons of
lessons to learn that all can be
unpacked at another time but I truly
believe fundamentally communication is
the response and when we get that right
everything else Falls in place data is a
key component of transparency and the
expectations for
immediate um data overwhelmed our old
Legacy state agency data system
and while doctors and nurses were busy
treating individuals other heroic folks
were in the background they were
building brand new Data Systems to
transmit and visualize data in ways and
at rates at which we had never done
before so that's just sort of context
for where we were three Co taught us
again and again um and probably still
teaches us to pay attention to the kids
pay attention to our loved ones in Long
term care facilities those that needed
to work on the front lines of our
hospitals our schools and other
essential Services covid was a
collective trauma and the impacts were
uneven among different groups of people
four the Swiss cheese approach to
protection is the way to go it's one of
my favorite analogies that came out of
um the pandemic and that simply was to
refresh your mind maybe you remember Dr
Ben Chan talking about the Swiss cheese
apprach when he was on WMUR um each
layer of protection from mask to air
filtration to social distancing to
vaccines is imperfect on its own there
are essentially small holes in each of
those strategies you can find a hole in
just about everything but if you layer
those pieces of Swiss cheese together
hopefully where the holes don't align
you can develop a stronger protection
system the best thing about the s twis
cheese approach is that it can change
over time layering um more or fewer
approaches as needed either by a
community or by a person with their own
individual risks so again we have its
additive there are many layers of
protection none of them are perfect on
their own when you combine them together
you generally get greater
protection and then
finally there are many potential
Solutions all with strengths and
challenges on almost every measure New
Hampshire fared better than other
states while we have lost about 3,300
Granite Staters to co we had the second
lowest death rate in the country second
only to Hawaii that was able to close
its borders and is an island so I don't
count them um they count but they don't
count um one St study noted that new
Hampshire's major advantage was that New
Hampshire's residents reported the
highest level of interpersonal trust
some of those folks have tied that to
our culture in form of government sort
of work that we're doing right here
today um some of it to our small town
Civic engagement our volunteerism in in
our communities our beautiful outdoor
environment which we talked a little bit
about last time in New Hampshire I put
this up to the fact that we work through
our differences and I think that that's
what's really important as we think
about this whole C pandemic response
thousands of your neighbors and your
constituents stepped up into key
leadership positions and helped us get
through the pandemic they were National
Guard members teachers local fire local
EMS municipalities doctors nurses even a
few people in Public Health Trust
relationships and Community is good for
your mental and physical health
resilience and I can't help but believe
that is what helped us weather those
three years so I will those are just my
opening comments and I will take you on
this little journey now so again get
back in your way back machine um back in
January
2020 uh 2020 January 21st 2020 the
Department of Health and Human Service
sent out its first notice to healthcare
providers in something that's called a
Han a health alert Network it's a
message it used to go by fax machine way
back in the day it is now emailed um and
it basically says to doctors nurses
healthc Care Systems there's something
out there we use it for all sorts of
things and back in the first Han that we
sent about covid-19 was on January 21st
2020 by January 31st there was a federal
Public Health Emergency declared as we
understood what was going on
internationally and as the West Coast
post started to deal with covid-19
Washington state was where the first
cases of covid-19 um landed by March 2nd
uh New Hampshire had its first covid-19
case um but also on March 2nd our New
Hampshire Public Health laboratory
started testing and had the capacity to
test for covid-19 I will remind you of
something that's probably lost on all of
us we all remember supply chain
shortages comically we remember no
toilet paper any we for any one of us
but one of the things that was truly
difficult for us right out of the gate
was the swab it takes to test for
covid-19 it's a fancy Q-tip and you may
remember it from back then it sort of
felt like it went up to your brain as it
tickled you everyone was searching for
swabs that was what took in those first
weeks of March we were desperate first
and it was the first inkling of the
supply chain issues that we would
experience through throughout much of
the early pandemic we put up 211 lots of
people had questions we created 211 to
to answer some of those we set up call
centers the National Guard was helpful
by March 23rd so you remember the first
case was March 2nd by the 23rd we had
100 cases of covid in New Hampshire a
visual image I will give to you is
originally on our in the public health
um in a in a locked room there was a
place where we put the you know initials
and numbers of cases on a whiteboard and
they were written in very big letters
right away and then the words got
smaller those numbers and initials kept
getting smaller and smaller and then you
had to flip the Whiteboard and then
there was a second whiteboard and then
the whiteboards all went away I mean
that is to me one of the earliest
memories I have of the ways in which we
were not prepared for the speed at which
things were
going um by the 16th Governor sonunu um
started issuing some restrictions um and
the uh 15th he he had um yes I'm
sorry I skipped over so the declare
you're right my shoots and letters I
look down to the wrong place so uh our
first state of emergency was March 13
that is um again after the federal
public em Health Emergency declared in
January New Hampshire declared its 1 in
March 13th we o we the governor created
the state um emergency Operation Center
for covid that was managed by Homeland
Security and then we started seeing
those um other issues those other
emergency declarations by March 23rd we
had the first death in the state um we
then started seeing some temporary
restrictions on Gatherings and our
stay-at-home orders started by March
26th by March 30th the National Guard
was activated to assist with the
response and by April 3rd we had 500
cases of covid-19 go to the next page
here um by April those numbers are
exponential as I said you know this is
no longer on a whiteboard we had to
develop very robust Data Systems to
manage um by April the governor uh de
created two things that were very
important to this response one the
governor's office for emergency relief
and Recovery gopher as it's known to all
of us handled much of the federal money
that was coming in for Relief then
similarly at the same about the same
time Governor established the governor's
reopening task force the economic
reopening task force understanding that
our our society our businesses they
could not stay closed forever and so
very quickly the governor did something
that was quite radical in comparison to
other states which was to put
legislators like yourselves paired with
Community experts industry experts on a
panel to say how do we get back open and
did that in a transparent way um did
phone calls back we wasn't even on teams
or zooms but did phone calls at some
point every day sometimes a couple times
a week back down to once a week um where
the public could listen in on those
deliberations um you uh there are some
other pieces so by May you'll see that
the first antiviral treatments start
arriving in in the department and in New
Hampshire We Begin testing more than
1,500 people a day for
covid-19 and by June 15th the
stay-at-home order
expired we began to open up by June 2020
hotels lodging campgrounds began to open
up in limited ways with the guidance of
that reopening task force and meanwhile
sort of while other things were
happening this was where we were working
with the supply chain around things like
gloves
masks and personal protective equipment
we all learned the letters PPE and New
Hampshire organized the largest cargo
flight in in the Manchester Airport um
history Landing with PPE for New
Hampshire we developed warehousing to be
able to distribute and make sure to
house it to store it and distribute it
so we could get that out on the ground
where it
belongs um we now by August have some
early rapid antigen tests those first
rapid tests that we all now have sitting
in our closets at home but that they did
not come out until August of
2020 um by September when I spoke about
data we launched um a covid-19 dashboard
that was updated daily if you can recall
back in the early days even you know
before September there were daily press
conferences and daily briefings by
September we had all that information
available to anyone with a couple of
clicks of your fingers by November 18th
500 people have died and by November
20th um the governor suoo issued a mass
mandate for residents over five years
old by December
2020 is when we had our first vaccine
available and administered in New
Hampshire I'm going to remind myself
here I'm going to pull up um the uh
uh the distribution plan maybe I won't
do that off my my phone maybe I'll do it
from memory here um we had if you'll
recall it vaccines were in very short
supply when they first came out and so
every state had a rollout plan for
vaccinations New Hampshire did this
differently and so this is an example
where New Hampshire did things a little
bit different than the rest of the
country we looked at our own data and we
said what's right for New Hampshire CDC
was recommending in those first early um
rollouts to focus on just essential
workers the definitions of a central
worker was pretty Loosey Goosey um and
instead we took a hard look at the data
and the way in which we rolled out these
limited supplies early on was within our
phase one it was for high-risk health
care workers and First Responders
because those were the folks on the
ground also included in that we knew
that the people who were dying at this
time were 85 and older and in long-term
care and so that's where we put the
vaccines is was among the people who
were dying again vaccine the state of
New Hampshire did not require
vaccines um at the time Health Care
Facilities may have required them in
their facility but there was no State
order requiring a vaccine by quickly um
soon after we rolled out a vaccine for
anyone over the age of 75 and uh and
folks that were medically vulnerable
with two or more conditions by phase 2A
we continued to open up the door as more
vaccines came in we opened it up to
individuals 65 or 65 to age 74 school
and um Child Care staff those were the
folks in that phase 2A phase 2B was age
50 to 60 before again taking an
age-based approach because that's where
the risk was and then um after that
medically VA young medically vulnerable
folks under the age of 50 and then
finally everyone else so that was the
staging at which we um expanded yes and
just that do you have uh dates for like
when each of those you know what I can
get those to you because we um what I
was able to find right now was sort of
our original plan and we were actually
able to speed that up so I can get that
back to you but I don't have it right
now you're very welcome so that was the
vaccine roll out so meanwhile back in
December we were doing those rollouts we
started again with healthc care
providers you know Christmas day 20120
um is the is the time we saw deaths Peak
throughout the entire pandemic at an
average over 12 deaths per week so
vaccine was rolling out while we were
seeing these I'm going to use the word
again unprecedented numbers of deaths so
folks that had not had any opportunity
to be vaccine vaccinated as we did the
rollout you may all remember we created
13 State managed covid-19 vaccine sites
and those were uh resourced by the
National Guard and other um Partners
along the way many of us remember
driving up to them or standing in line I
got my first vaccine and what used to be
the Sears in the Steeplegate Mall the
you know the place where you used to get
your oil changed that's where folks
started getting their vaccine by January
25th nearly 200,000 people signed up for
a vaccination again I will just note uh
prior to this we had no way to register
200,000 people for anything and so that
was part of the data systems that needed
to be created and quite frankly
resourced to be able to handle that
level of Interest February 11th we're up
to a thousand deaths reported
um we uh but by February 19th Again by
2021 um it's important to not the
governor we have vaccines available and
so the governor orders um that at least
that schools have at least two days of
in-person instruction for public schools
K to 12 so again the order of this is
important we have vaccines it's time to
get kids back in school um we March we
had our first vaccination events at the
New Hampshire Speedway maybe some of you
participated in that as well those were
phenomenal Affairs and a Real Testament
to the Partnerships in New Hampshire
that allowed us to use resources of how
do you get as those vaccination dates
were opening to your to your point
earlier um as more and more how do you
actually do that in a way and so the
speedway was extraordinarily um uh uh
collaborative with us in working with
Homeland Security to organize that those
events right there by the time we have
vaccine we hear the CDC say fully vaccin
they start giving guidance about how
fully vaccinated people can safely
interact with each other by March 22nd
everything is available to everyone 16
and over um along the way uh the mask
mandate it gets lifted soon after those
vaccines are available to
everyone um and then um by May 3rd over
half of the new New Hampshire residents
over 16 have received their first
vaccine the um by the 21st the state op
Emergency Operations Center and the
joint information center close a
tremendous moment just in terms of uh
Pro the work that it takes among state
agencies that seoc as we call it the
state emergency operation oper Center
had been opened for over a year 7 days a
week with folks on call 24 hours a day
and so it was able to be closed June
30th
2021 right in July we started knowing
that there were individuals who were
unable to access vaccines in places like
the New Hampshire Speedway or at our
vaccine sites we launched our vaccine
van and that was able to provide
vaccines in communities um and among um
folks that were homebound which was
really
important um again July 23rd 2021
legislation that was passed I'm sure
many of you were involved with um that
prohibited state and local government
agencies from requiring proof of
vaccination to access facilities or
Services vaccine has been
voluntary uh 20 uh October 29th FDA
authorizes vaccine for ages 5 to 11 so
kiddos can start now having the
opportunity if that's what their
families want by November 23rd 2021
Governor um cunu um issues an order to
address hospit capacity maybe you all
can remember this this was a very
critical moment in November December of
um in January uh between 2021 late 2021
and early 2022 our hospitals were um
teaming at that point the at the highest
level we had almost 600 people
hospitalized for covid-19 in our
hospitals uh and our hospitals were at
the breaking point and so the governor
issued orders we created flexibilities
for those hospitals so in order to care
for them the National Guard came in and
participated and tried to relieve our
hospitals and our doctors and nurses
from some of the administrative
functions or sort of the environmental
functions we had uh National Guard
members delivering meals within those
hospitals this was for our Health Care
Systems this was probably one of the
scariest moments when those numbers
started to really um get
high again our deaths peaked at about 12
deaths per week in December there's um
not a lot of um coincidence around that
our respiratory rates I've gone back and
looked at the data over time the weeks
between Christmas and New Year are Bad
News Bears that is bad for everybody
it's bad for respiratory disease we're
together we're sick we're all you know
we're with our family with our friends
and that is always whether it's flu RSV
covid those weeks between Christmas and
New Year's are always bad and we saw
that once again play out with covid we
saw it years later um the next year in
2022 with children with RSV if you may
remember that once kids were back so
this is a normal pattern but certainly
scary by June um again we have vaccines
for the youngest children age six months
to five years um by August CDC is no
longer recommending quarantine for those
exposed to covid-19 you remember we used
to have quarantine if you knew somebody
you'd also have to quarantine they were
still recommending isolation if you were
sick but no longer if your close contact
were sick did you have to quarantine as
well by March 23rd we have the
publication of that report that I was
talking about where New Hampshire had
had the second lowest death rate and
they really investigated some of those
societal factors that led to that that
could have perhaps contributed in this
idea that New Hampshire is a truly
unique and special place in the sense
that we work together that we have trust
in our interpersonal relationships and
within our communities by May 6 we have
3,000 deaths in New Hampshire and by May
11th 2023 the federal Public Health
Emergency ended so again there were many
other pieces that I think all of us
might remember from there um but I hope
that that was a good overview for you of
just sort of the Shoots and Ladders
where we were thank
you does anyone have any questions or
comments thatly to make representative
Weber
please thank you so much Madam chair and
thank you for just taking my comment
which is that uh you did some discussion
of when vaccines were rolled out for the
various age ranges and like your
whiteboards that got more and more dense
I'm I'm not sure integrating it into
this graphic is what is needed but
having that timeline as well yes would
be really helpful my own memory is that
I wrote a I wrote a summary for our Our
Town web page every week based on that
data that you had on the dashboard and
also giving people information about all
the stuff that nobody had ever thought
about before I mean how to apply for
unemployment compensation for people
who'd never ever had to do so before in
their lives and who could apply on all
of that stuff and and uh people got to
the point of relying on that to the
point where when there wasn't any news
one week and I didn't write it I got
email saying are you sick you know what
can we do but I think that kind of
timeline is is also helpful and I um I
probably the response in terms of things
like unemployment compensation and all
of that is probably outside of what this
committee does but um having the
response in terms of um when when things
were available I think would be helpful
and thank you and thank you for this
which is wonderful oh thank you and
thank you so much for that comment to
your point we had a graphic that I
almost shared with you but it w the
original graphic around the roll out we
were able to roll out sooner than the
graphic even originally said because we
were we were rolling out vaccines as we
had them available from the federal
government I you know I think it's
important to note um the the federal
government controlled the vaccine Supply
um and they sent it to States we did not
in the during the state of emergency um
they were free to the the vaccine itself
was free the state didn't pay for
vaccines individuals didn't pay for
vaccines um and then by the time the
emergency the state of emergency was
over those vaccines have been
commercialized and now there's a cost
Associated to them and now the state has
nothing to do um with that distribution
so but I will um go back and we'll see
if we can get the exact dates when each
of those opened we've got to dig a
little
more uh
ran thank you chair thanks for taking my
question again um can you remind me how
covid deaths were defined like in terms
and has that changed over time I sure
vaguely remember that so thank thanks
for that question because I know it's a
you know a lot of uh there's been a lot
of consternation about that over time
sort of nationally and even here in New
Hampshire New Hampshire always took a
very conservative approach to um covid
deaths one of the good things about New
Hampshire is we're small um our state
epidemi ologist reviewed every single
death record and there needed to be
covid on the death record for it to be
classified as a covid death so again
your providers are the ones who
determine whether a death is co or not
the state department uh of Health then
confirmed every single one of those
deaths it takes a little while to do
that for a couple of reasons one just to
gather that information death data is
always lags a little bit um and we were
also collecting information from other
states so if was a New Hampshire
resident that died in Boston it takes a
little bit longer so that's a little bit
of a lagging indicator it's one of the
reasons why for us hospitalization still
is and was the sort of indicator that
was like what we were really paying
attention quite frankly more than cases
after early on because hospitalization
was really severity of of disease um we
can come back another time and I can
give deeper um explanation of that
epidemiological process of going through
and confirming each case count at the
chair's
discretion absolutely quickly um so how
does that compare to how other states
were doing it just thinking if we're
ranking ourselves very highly other
states um use respiratory illness
sometimes as well as covid and um so I
we'd be happy to bring my my epies back
and really walking through
that representative
Penza so I'd like to understand um in
regards with testing and I think it's uh
I think you mentioned in it was probably
at some point in March when you had a
when you had a um like a preliminary
testing that was going on so I'd like to
understand when the PCR tests were come
in and I want to I want to understand
the Cycles I want to know those cycle
numbers so from the time that testing
started and where cycle numbers changed
I I'm sure I understand about the cycle
number if you could explain that to me
okay so um PCR test as you know um so
PCR test as you know if you um it'll
test positive for anything um for covid
um if you cycle it up high enough you
can keep spinning it for that so it can
also test for someone that had been
recovered from covid Corona viruses are
in everything it can have someone that
just has the common cold flu can test
positive for it and all of that
especially early on testing has gone has
has come a long way from in the
beginning and I'd like to know what
those cycle numbers were sure I can't
provide that for you today I will need
to bring in my testing experts because I
don't want to give you misinformation in
that space But that again for the um
committee that seems like something that
would be a great time to spend a little
time on on how on the evolution of
testing thank
you uh representative
Belcher thank you madam chair and I'm
not sure how exactly we should go about
this um I have I have a few different
questions they should be short I guess
I'll just ask for follow-ups between
just keep right sounds good um so I'd
like to get a little bit into some of
the sort of specifics as it comes some
of the data and if you if you don't have
it at the moment that's fine we can
either get it provided or we can have
some later testimony on it and that
would be fine so just let me know but
you uh testified to the Swiss cheese
approach which makes some degree of
sense and I think just to highlight what
we're looking at is the idea is you
throw everything at it and collectively
everything will bring down the the uh
the the ability of the virus to spread
um so since we are a science-based
committee can you tell me um what the
estimated R not of the virus was at the
time of adoption of the Swiss cheese
approach the what the estimated or not
would have been or what the what the
target was with that approach and what
data there is that demonstrates the r
not was reduced by that approach sure so
um R not is uh an epidemiological
function um I can't give you those
numbers off the top my I've got a lot of
numbers in my head I don't have those
numbers on the top of my head today so
we can come back and talk about that at
another time again I was simply prepared
and asked to talk about a timeline today
but I can tell you that we were looking
at those numbers and really it's about
the r is the rate of spread and is it
exponential is it not exponential and so
um you know some of the ways the um ways
we talked about it was flattening the
curve that was the other language that
we used of we expected it to go up and
we actually saw that slope for the
mathematic you know mathematicians in
the room that slope get a little bit
shorter and so what we certainly saw
early you know when you had a ton of
those slices of of Swiss cheese and we
had to do physical protections things
like the stay-at-home order masking um
we saw some of those number we could
slow some of those numbers down um as
vaccines were available and individuals
wanted to not have those restrictive
policies especially for economic reasons
and all sorts of reasons kids needed to
be in school we then loosened up some of
those stay-at-home policies they those
went away people interacted more the VAC
you know the spread went up but we had
another piece of protection which was
vaccin so the those were the complicated
decisions you know policy decisions that
were made we can talk we can show you
that there are a number of um uh places
like John's Hopkins that tracks for each
state that are um not number and those
were used as part of the dis the
discovery and policymaking at the time
that's what I can tell
you and if I may um do a slightly
different uh topic you I believe you
said we have approximately and very
tragically lost about 3,500 New
Hampshire residents 3300 3300 thank you
a New Hampshire residents from Co I
wanted to ask because there has been so
much and I and I understand the
difficulty with Discerning exactly this
number um I wanted to ask are these can
we can we confirm with a high degree of
certainty that these are all deaths from
covid as opposed to Deaths with
covid I believe that our data is that uh
suggests that covid was the leading
contributor to those deaths thank you
and if I may on that on that same topic
um
there were I I've seen reports and I
don't know whether this is totally
accurate or not um is it true that there
were um perhaps Medicare or Medicaid or
something of that sort paying out at a
higher rate if the death was labeled as
covid versus something else I am not
aware of that I am also not a Medicaid
expert but I am not aware that that
happened that certainly wasn't part of
our policy um decision-making algorithm
thank you and if I
may
okay uh regarding the uh stay-at-home
order uh you testified I believe at the
last hearing that from very early on in
the summer of 2020 New Hampshire
residents were urged to go Outdoors
because it was thought that outdoor
transmission would be negligible so I'm
asking can you speak to what what seems
to be a little bit of a contradiction
between that and the the stay-at-home
order which involved also everything
from beaches were closed to the closure
of trails in the White Mountains and uh
protesters gathering in front of this
state house who were threatened with
arrest for Gathering can you can you
speak to that discrep sure I you know
while I and I don't know that I use the
word negligible but it certainly was um
you know Outdoors is better than inside
is what I would say Outdoors is better
than inside uh whenever you gather
closely together however that adds risk
and so I think those were the issues in
those weeks early on trying to manage
both of those needs both the needs for
people to have opportunities to go
outside and also not Gather in a way
that was clustered together so all of us
have been been to Hampton Beach perhaps
on a 85 degree day when it's sunny and
you know you're blanket to blanket with
folks that is probably riskier than
being by yourself in your backyard
uh represent
pit so I also have several questions and
I start with first one but first of all
thank you for this timeline uh it's very
helpful uh and uh also thank you for
being ready uh to come again and
testifying about your process of
confirming each case because uh it I
think it would be helpful for us to
understand how provider determined uh
covid death and how DHHS was going
through process of confirming it uh so
um uh I think it would be uh useful uh
to have similar timelines for different
uh strategies or different measures uh
and uh for example thank you for
including uh vaccine measure here and uh
um uh and for example different measure
would be mask so specifically timeline
for how masking recommendations were
evolving and um my my uh preference
would be if possible including some uh
scientific
uh um scientific timeline uh because
some of those measures probably were
Guided by politics and uh and
administrative uh
suggestions uh for example in the
beginning people were told not to buy
masks but it was more like political
decision to save masks for First
Responders um represent po um we're
going to do this on scientific data we
don't want to bring the politics into
this yeah yeah that's why I I thank you
that's why I'm asking to include like
like um if some of these uh decisions
were based on science if you could
include some
some that for for example uh when uh uh
Dr Benjamin Chan testified that uh new
dat data showed that there some a
increased risk for myocarditis for uh
young males and uh male kids so
something like that uh uh when when it
was
already published in scientific paper
reviewed and acknowledged uh by DHHS
that it need to affect policies for
example on vaccine recommendations for
kids so some scientific points would be
helpful for timeline from my
perspective uh representative Penza do
you had another question
okay does anyone else on the committee
have any questions represent
Merchant thank you madam chair and also
thank you M chy for bringing this
timeline it's very informative and very
helpful would you speak to one of the
things you talked about was the
challenge not just here in New Hampshire
but throughout the whole country the
supply chain disruptions and what that
meant to the state here I want to say
commend the state for bringing in such a
large flight into Manchester Airport not
sure how it landed how it got out but
thank you for doing it but talk about
the challenges the state faced with
trying to get supplies that you needed
so desperately to try to solve and
tackle some of the problems um I think
you know had any of us been talking in
you know 20 uh 20120 or December in 2019
I I don't know that any of us would have
thought that the success of a pandemic
would really rest so much on supply
chain and Logistics and that is the
place where we certainly had some
preparations but even at a federal level
there's a federal strategic National
supply of of supplies um that was
inadequate right away um and states in
some cases were really left to fend on
their own because there were limit the
feds also could not provide that in
provide that those sort of supplies and
when we talk about some of those
supplies we are talking about medical
grade Mass the n95 surgical masks
talking about gloves um those were
things that were just in short supply we
had Daily Calls where we talked about
the literal number of boxes that we had
available that day and where we could
send them um and so we learned a lot uh
prior to the pandemic for example
Department of Health and Human Services
had a very small room that was our
warehouse of stuff um we now rent
something that looks a little bit more
like a small Costco where we can
organize distribute use data systems
actually have logistic Data Systems some
of the best hires we had were folks like
from Walmart who really helped us
Implement how do you manage all of this
all of this product coming and going um
so that was tremendously difficult as I
mentioned early on you know we could
test if we only had swabs and so that
made some of the decisions you know back
to your question around um earlier about
political decisions versus scientific
decisions I would say that those were
not necessarily that they were not
necessarily political decisions but just
simply logistical decisions where you
only have five of something and you have
to decide where they go um luckily New
Hampshire never had a ration care never
had to really do those things so we were
fortunate in that way but it took a
tremendous amount of effort and still
does to make sure that we've got
resources out into the community one of
the things I'm most proud of is that not
only did we prioritize and get equipment
to long-term care facilities where we
saw such incredible um Devastation from
covid from to our hospitals um but also
into our communities and again I think
that's where we did really well we
worked very hard that our municipalities
had access to things and we tried to be
as transparent as possible and as
collaborative as possible Homeland
Security did a great job of connecting
with the municipalities with um
different uh with schools um with even
summer camps we were one of the first
states to open up summer camps for kids
and the way we were able to do that was
to be able to make sure that those camps
had access to testing and to PPE and
guidance on how to keep Kids
Safe representative
Weber I had two other thoughts about
responses that I I don't know how you
deal with these scientifically but maybe
you can um and if there was any kind of
understanding of whether it helped or
not but I'm thinking of the individual
response and and as as several people
have alluded to uh New Hampshire is a
state where everybody wants to pitch in
and I'm thinking of the people who seed
thousands of masks and it was sort of
surreal because here we were were using
technology uh and nothing had changed
but people were sewing lots of masks and
uh for my nursing home making um turning
old G shirts
into um protective garments that could
be
rewashed and so I wonder if there's any
kind of evaluation out
there as to whether that actually helped
with infection and things or whether it
simply served to create both keep people
busy and create a sense of purpose and
unity which is not a bad thing but it
would be useful to know going forward
what kind of things the civilian
population can do to help that are the
the most actually effective to deal with
the problem you're faced with and I'm
thinking about certain other things and
this may be more for the after Action
Report that's being prepared but there
were certain things that we did uh and
I'm thinking specifically of the setting
up of mobile hospitals everywhere which
hindsight being 2020 were not needed and
we're very grateful that they weren't
but I certainly don't think you could
have
ignored looking at the numbers as we
were looking at them the possibility
that we might need them and we certainly
saw all the pictures from all the other
places where they certainly had no place
to put very sick people so I those kind
of evaluations I think if they are
available anywhere would be helpful but
not sure that they are yeah I I'm not
sure they are right now I think our the
the larger after action report is going
to talk a little bit about um you know
our Playbook we've been preparing for a
pandemic forever um The Playbook was
essentially for an influenza and an
influenza event and you know based on
what we know about influenza and the you
know it's all modeling at that point but
it's preparedness work it's the way all
of us prepare for everything in our
homes we we don't always get it right
but you know you have some things
together and so you know the
preparedness Playbook suggested you're
going to need those mobile hospitals
luckily we did not need them that's
great but that's what we knew to do at
the time and it really helped us
mobilize get the right people together
to make some of those um decisions about
what was in fact the right the the
better approach for caring for
individuals with this particular virus
to your point around masks I'm not aware
I mean certainly I you know as a public
health professional I can tell you that
the cloth masks are not as effective as
the surgical masks which are not as
effective as the n95s we knew that but
again you PL you mirrored that with the
supply chain issues where we knew we
needed to have those that PPE the most
effective PPE in our healthc care and
long-term care um centers because that's
where the people who with the most risk
were and so you know so again the Swiss
cheese there's uh there's some
protection wearing that cloth mask I I
just threw ACH away in my home I was
doing a little cleaning it feels good to
throw them away I'm sure everyone else
has done the same thing um you know
they're not as effective and I think we
knew that or that was not unknown to us
at the time but when you have a limited
supply of something you do what you need
to do to until we get that bigger supply
and then we evolve was the hardest thing
about this pandemic is that things were
always
changing repr
leus we heard after the vir vaccines
came out we were getting
numbers at least
weekly about um infections infection
rate and how much was vaccinated people
and how much was unvaccinated
people and I'm wondering how were you
collecting that data and um how accurate
was that data sure so um soon uh
especially as the um the rapid tests
came out um collecting data on cases was
difficult you know we knew that because
as soon as you could take a test at home
that test was not reported to anywhere
the way it works if a hospital or health
care provider um provided a covid-19
test at the time no longer is the case
but at the time that information went
directly to the Department of Health uh
because it was part of this uh emergency
so we knew that there was always a
little bit of information that we did
not know um and often we use data from
um the studies that created the vaccines
to understand the effectiveness of the
vaccines that's some of it but we knew
early on that as time went on that that
information would be less um accurate
over time and so we stopped collecting
it because it simply was less accurate
and we couldn't make decisions based on
it
so if you knew it was less accurate and
you stopped collecting it what were you
basing the reports that we saw so when
during those reports we had the data
because data was most most people were
getting their tests by a medical
provider as that as that shift happened
which is is when we shifted back to a
different we shifted to a different
strategy does that make sense yes thank
you yeah r p it uh thank you Madame
chair and thank you for taking another
question uh uh it was very uh uplifting
to hear that New Hampshire had second
lowest uh uh death rate after Hawaii but
also you mentioned uh incredible
Devastation and long-term care
facilities so uh is it true that New
Hampshire overall fed good but there
were some um pockets uh uh such as uh uh
LTC facilities when where New Hampshire
probably was not as good compared to
other state I don't know that I have the
comparison of our long-term care
facilities to other states we have you
know again folks were uh some of the
national folks that were looking at data
are surprised because New Hampshire of
course is so much older than other
states they assumed New Hampshire were
to have higher rates of of death and we
didn't um but but you know we managed
our long-term care facilities to the
best degree that we can and by we I mean
the long-term care facilities themselves
as well as with the the support from the
state um one death is too many and death
among the long-term care facilities are
all each of those are tragic so I I
while I am proud of comparatively how
we've done I don't want any
misunderstanding one death is too
many represent
Merchant Madam chair unfortunately have
to go to another committee meeting um in
regards to the next scheduled meeting is
it still going to be March 8th in the
morning uh so there's been really quick
um not sure would afternoon work for you
I believe uh representative not not on
the eth unfortun I have another conflict
on the eth of another committee so I
will send out an email to the entire
committee to see who can be here in the
morning and who cannot what what works
best for and will go with the majority
unfortunately and thank you for leading
the leading the charge as the chair and
also miss Tilly thank you for your time
today thank you very much representative
represent Penza
please so I remembered my question from
before I'd like to go back
to um and I I'm not sure you know was
you know a collaboration of course
between uh the governor's office and and
Dr Shan and DHHS um why weren't there
public pivots when we knew things were
like asymptomatic spread you know I know
that there's some other Representatives
here that have asked about um you know
outdoors and beaches and all that kind
of stuff we knew very early on that that
was not true um that was pushed a lot so
where why wasn't there public um why
wasn't there why wasn't there a a public
why did those those things keep being
said kind of beaten to a dead horse um
about um asymptomatic spread when we
knew that early on I'm not sure I'm
fully understanding your question right
you asking about that um why did we say
there was asymptomatic spread and are
you contending there was not
asymptomatic spread is that
understanding I just want to understand
your question so early on in there was
tons of talk with social distancing and
all of these things that have now been
completely um like in a sense disproven
that those weren't helpful um so I'm I'm
asking and we knew that early on that
asymptomatic spread was not valid so why
wasn't there a pivot at that point I'm
not sure that asymptom asymptomatic
spread is not valid I think we have
cases where there was asymptomatic
spread so I just want to start there you
know we know that it is more likely you
are more likely to get covid-19 with
someone who has heavy viral shedding
who's coughing at you know and sort of
spreading disease I I agree with you on
that that is you're more likely but I I
would not suggest that there is no um
chance of asymptomatic spread especially
early in the pandemic when we had very
little immune system towards um covid-19
so um you know I I can go back and have
additional conversations I don't know
again I was prepared to talk about
timeline today I'm not fully prepared to
get into the scientific pieces of that
um but I do want to say that there
certainly have been cases observed cases
where it appears that there was a
symptomatic
thank you so much for being here I
really like the timeline thank you um
but I do find
um think um I have a couple of questions
um of the 3300 deaths do you have a
breakdown of Ages like age groups I
think that would be
beneficial um and of those deaths do we
know if who was vaccinated and who was
not um is yeah I can certainly tell you
the ages and by far the age group with
the highest proportion of deaths are
those 85 and older we know that that's
that's who really died we also saw over
time in terms of cases and illness you
know there were times where even a sort
of what I called working age adults
people who look like me were also
getting sick because we were out and
about um more than say the population of
65 to 75 or 65 to 80 that tended to be
more conservative in their interactions
people were out and about you know had
more cases and sometimes became more ill
and and hospitalized especially if they
had chronic diseases um vaccinated or
not um that data becomes a little bit
more tricky to get and I I need to go
back and talk to the epidemiologists
again because we don't have the death
record does not say whether you're
vaccinated okay I was just wondering if
that was something that was readily
available um but a breakdown I think of
the deaths of the age groups I think
would be a telling and I guess and I
don't know as you said you can kind of
almost group them like at first it was
like between uh you know January 2020
and March 2020 for say you know the
highest group was this age group and
this age group also I don't know if
that's something I don't want to place a
ton of burden on you but I didn't know
how accessible that was um to do sure we
certainly have available right now you
can Google it on our covid-19 you just
Google New Hampshire DHHS covid-19 and
those dashboards are all available and
you'll see the this is the little line
of deaths that go up and down over the
course of the Year you'll see that
December January time and it'll come
down in December January time and it'll
come down and you so you can see both
hospitalizations and deaths over time we
don't have that trend line Broken Out by
age but we do have other data available
and so if you have a specific ask we can
follow up afterwards and and we can run
that data for you but I encourage
everyone you know there was a time we
all looked at that covid-19 dashboard a
lot most people have forgotten it
existed it's still up there um we don't
update it every day but we do update it
routinely um and it provides a lot of
information I have to thank um uh our
friends from the hospitals I know that
the New Hampshire Hospital Association
is behind me um they provide a weekly
report on hospitalizations because those
are no longer um uh covid does not have
to be reported to the Department of
Health and Human Services anymore but
they provide us an aggregate again that
trend line of what hospitalizations are
so we can be prepared if we start seeing
them inch up we saw it inching up um we
saw capacity in hospital inching up even
this Christmas New Year's time we were
okay but many of us were on pins and
needles much like last year we saw it
inch up for Pediatrics for RSV where we
actually really got to a very critical
spot of the number of pediatric beds in
the state not covid but in
RSV uh thank you for that um another
question I have is early on when people
were being hospitalized
um for whatever reason I I my dad was
one of those in April of 2020 he did not
have covid but he was
hospitalized fortunately for us the EMT
said make sure you take your cell phone
in charger um what was most distressing
and I don't know how this guidance came
up um was the fact that loved ones
couldn't get in to see the the patients
that were very sick um
even uh
in I'm not sure in New Hampshire but in
another state uh as late as even
2021 uh with parents that were you know
dying uh getting siblings to get into to
see them for the last last time was
pretty tough how
did and I don't know if DHHS had
anything if your department had anything
to do with that guidance at the hospital
level or if that was um the hospitals
himself or was that Homeland Security uh
could you sure it certainly wasn't
Homeland Security um so they're off the
hook for that um from DHHS we have no
regulatory control over the hospital so
there was no regulation that we put in
place around that um the hospitals made
decisions we provided recommendations at
times around infection control and I you
know I want to First say how um I know
yourself and so many people who had
loved ones in the hospital in 2020 how
difficult that was my I had a relative
as well who passed away um in a in a
facility and unable to be attended by
the people that love her um and that was
hard for for all of us and part of that
is it's it's complicated so it was a
question of how is this spread do you
have enough PPE do you need to conserve
the PPE for the nurses and the doctors
that are in that space and so you know
what I would simply say is um those
systems made the best decisions with the
information that they had at hand and
over time change those policies I think
this is as I said covid was traumatic
for all of us at times and things
changed and at as we had more
information things
changed um and and thank you for that
and I'm very sorry that that happened uh
to your family um but my other question
along that lines is you you mentioned
that you issued guidance about the
infections to the hospital system is
that correct yes okay um and in that
guidance would it have stated anything
about limiting access to those patients
I would have to go back and look at that
guidance to see what it said exactly one
of the things I I um recommend to all of
you if you're interested in where quite
frankly we got many of these data points
today um on the DHHS website is this
those Health alert networks those Hans
and so you can go through and see what
guidance was throughout and we were
issuing Hans almost weekly at some point
so there are many many Hans very
detailed with the guidance that came out
at the time okay um the the um
um the other thing is is
um at a county level dealing with the
nursing
homes um we were seeing a large
um they were having issues because they
couldn't let people into to do work or
even deliver product if they couldn't
prove that they were
vaccinated do you know where that
guidance came from some of that guidance
was CMS guidance
okay thank you um and the other that's
centers for Medicaid and Medicare just I
hate speaking in acronyms I'm sorry it
it's okay I'm I'm not in the medical uh
field so thank you for clarifying that
for me um uh I do and my nephew is one
of the people at uh in charge of one of
the National Guard sites so I know how
uh trying that also was um too um
now in regards to the schools did you
provide the guidance to the governor for
the shutting down of schools or was that
something CA that came down from federal
I think you also mentioned Homeland
Security might have had something to do
with that can you kind of expound on
that a little bit again I will let you
when director buckon can come in and and
speak for Homeland Security that'll be
great um we uh you know the governor
ultimately made his decisions for his
executive orders he consulted with many
individuals um he consulted of course
with the Department of Health and Human
Services with Dr Chan with commissioner
shanet at the time he consulted with his
um you know resources ac across the
country as he made his
decisions representative Belcher thank
you madam chair uh just a couple more
that came up while this was all going on
uh first just based on that last
testimony you said TMS centers for
Medicaid or Medicare I'm no expert on
this is that a state or a federal agency
that's at the federal level Federal
agency excellent and uh one more if I
may um can you please speak to the sort
of States evolving understanding of the
threat of the co virus to minors and
children over time and if possible could
you compare it to the relative threat
posed by other illnesses such as cold
and flu as our sort of understanding of
alled sure and you know and and again I
would prefer to have someone like Dr
Chan speak to that he's a medical
provider I am not um I'm a trusty
bureaucrat uh but I what I will say is
um you know we as we didn't know about
anyone we did not know what the
long-term effects were going to be of
covid-19 on miners um as early on and
certainly as time went on WE gathered
more and more information and you know
as you saw even with vaccine roll out
the children the the children were the
last to be rolled out because they were
at the least at risk or perceived to be
at least at least at risk that's how we
did our roll out we saw the deaths among
the oldest population but there were
many questions along the way about what
the long-term effects of covid-19 would
be on developing brains and develop we
knew that there were neurological
effects and so over time that evolved
again Dr Cham would be much better to
talk about it than I
would thank you and just based on that
one one quick followup is and and I
think you're right that when you said
that we provided vaccines to Children
the latest point because at that time we
had some basic understanding that they
seem to be at the you know relatively
lowest risk for covid but can you speak
to the current um guidance from DHHS
that my understanding is still exists
that says children should still be
receiving the covid vaccine sure so our
recommendation says talk to your doctor
and make that decision based on your own
family's risks and your child's risk
that Co you know for the record you know
put on the record covid-19 is not
required for school or Child Care entry
nor has it ever been required for school
or Child Care entry um each family has
their own different set of constellation
of both the the risk to the child
themselves as well as to risk to family
members in the
household uh thank you uh so you
mentioned covid data
dashboard uh in the past uh there was
website uh uh covid 19. nh.gov
dasboard is it the same
thing because uh uh are you having a
difficult time finding so the way that I
get there the way that I get there very
very fancy is I just simply Google New
Hampshire DHHS co9 and you'll get a
link yes
yes and then you'll see data dashboard
you'll see a data place to
click thank you thank you representative
Penza um does anyone else have any other
questions I have one last one for you so
so sorry um what oh represented C please
oh thank you um it may well be the same
one um I was just going to ask um
thinking back on on all of this is is
there knowing what you know now are
there what things do you think you would
do differently in terms of having us
prepared or I know it's like very hard
with with the hindsight um hindsight is
f what information would you have have
wished to have had earlier um and what
what are things we can do to sure you
know I think the homeland security after
action report will get to that if you're
asking me personally I wish I had had a
stockpile of swabs for testing I wish
would have had a stockpile of masks um
those but in all honesty you know we
learned a lot about preparation and the
impacts to supply chains you know those
our plans were created in a time that
didn't have this sort of just in time
supply chain that we that exists for
toilet paper as well as for medical
supplies so those are things that are
huge lessons um you know the thing that
I would continue doing is always listen
to the community listen to a wide variet
iety of stakeholders and to be as
transparent as possible um and also to
make sure that we have the data that we
need and have the data infrastructure
that we
need ribson
licas yes I was wondering so I was
looking back on this timeline when did
Health Care Facilities mandate that
their workers had
vaccines and do you have any idea why
they did that were there recommendations
or whatever that you know about sure so
so certainly so I don't know that date
off the top of my head because we did
not issue that mandate right um so but
it came out shortly after vaccines were
available so again in in um 2021 that
would be vaccines first came available
to healthcare providers in December of
2020 so 2021 was really early 2021 was
the roll out again I think I am not the
expert here so you know I'm just going
to be uh you know you can find this out
Google it quicker than I can while I'm
sitting here but CMS also again centers
for Medicare and Medicaid had some
regulation and some thought around
vaccines um and healthc Care Systems
were doing the best they could to
support their patients and their other
staff so one of the things we did not
talk about here is really the whole
impact on Workforce it's outside of the
scope of this committee we have all
lived and breeded that and I know that
our colleagues at hospitals and
long-term care facilities were just
struggling as their staff were
sick okay thank
you I have one last question um and I'm
not sure if it's the purview of DHHS but
regarding the lockdowns basically of
public nursing homes um was that part of
your purview or was that some was
another department involved in that
guidance uh there was Federal guidance
at that point as well that um those
long-term care facilities were beholden
to um and we were working closely with
them throughout but again we can bring
back more information I don't want to
misre something it's been a long journey
so I have some dates in my head but I do
not have all of
them any other
questions um I have one last one for you
um based on this timeline and uh we will
have director buckton will be in uh at
the end of March hopefully um is there
anybody else that you think that we
should have in to kind of complement the
timeline and as you saw the variety of
questions that we the committee is
asking who you would suggest would be um
able to get to the heart of the
questions most efficiently so um I think
any well-formed
um questions and you've had a number of
questions today and and with the chair
if you can think about forming those um
I think we can be helpful at suggesting
who could answer those particular
questions I think the experience of
long-term care and hospitals is really
important and you should hear from them
they were on the front lines in a way
that was very different than many of
us thank you again so much I I
appreciate it um and I would ask the
committee if you have any questions uh
for uh Miss Tilly to forward them to me
so that they can be done under one email
um and uh if anything is too cumbersome
um for the Department just let me know
great thank you so much thanks for the
opportunity to be here thank you very
much uh is there anyone in the audience
that would like to speak to the timeline
or have anything to say to this
committee okay well I want to want to
thank everyone for being here and
um based I know that we are missing uh a
few members um but I'd like to uh have
with the committee uh discuss uh what
you feel should be some of the the next
few topics that we should be tackling um
so I'd like to hear from
you representative pitz uh I I don't
know if it's in order but uh uh uh since
hospitals uh were mentioned and I'm
seeing representative from Hospital
Association is here so I just wonder
what would be the appropriate question
for us to figure out how the best we can
uh direct questions to Hospital
Association when we have some and um
maybe ask uh Ju Ju Just One Day about it
if we need to figure out it
now okay thank you represent beler thank
you madam chair and what I would
recommend based on what I've seen for
the last two weeks now is that we may be
consider um doing our topic based on who
is available to testify on a given day
so we can formulate those questions
ahead of time and have sort of a for
instance if we could get um uh
the um DHHS and we could look at the
sort of orders that were involved and if
we can get uh do Chan or or uh other
medical professionals and we could go
over the the whole of the treatment
protocols and how the evolution of that
worked okay thank you anybody else uh
have any uh suggestions or ideas repr
like
us schools I'm particularly interested
in schools schs how they made their
decisions
um how they decided and both this is
both public and private schools all and
charter schools because they all made
different decisions and what those
decisions were and what the outcomes
were from the decisions they made and
um in
and and even like public schools in two
different towns would open up a
completely different times how did they
make that
decision um what actually how did they
use the money that they got from the
federal government and what was
effective what they found was effective
and not effective so that we'll know in
the future what you know so we'll have a
better idea of if this happens again how
do we deal with that well I know we
could probably approach the commissioner
of Education to come in but as far as
private schools I'm not sure exactly who
we would contact because they are
considered private schools um could we
could we ask like whoever the head or a
superintendent or whatever head of a
somebody from the ask them if they could
send us somebody who could talk about
what their responses were because I mean
we can learn from everybody right right
well we can I can reach out if anyone
has uh a person at a private school that
they would specifically like uh to reach
out to I would be willing to ask that um
Charter um the
um charter schools are also governed by
public guidance um I believe they would
have to kind of follow they have some
leeway uh you know to go so we can try
and reach out to maybe a couple of
different charter schools that maybe
handle it differently uh we know that
the private schools definitely handled
the whole situation differently and from
and from um Public Schools very
differently from town to town so to to
get a variety some who opened early some
who didn't some who did lexic glass some
who didn't some who you know just to get
an idea of what their responses were
what they did how effective it seemed to
be you know so that we can compare the
responses so I could reach out to the
superintendent in Town um to see if he
is available I don't know if anybody
else has anybody uh
that uh so representative prender if you
could uh help with the private school uh
reprentative cratan is there anything in
particular that uh you would like to see
discussed or have somebody in here yeah
um I'm not sure what I missed with the
the first meeting so apologies for that
um I'm definitely curious to know how um
as air quality has become something that
that we've been thinking about more um
for a variety of reasons but especially
transmissible diseases um where how far
we've come in terms of that and how
quickly that happened and what have been
the blockers to to getting that
happening um I think I think the school
system would be a great place to start
because in schools especially but also
public buildings and like you know
apartment buildings congregate housing
yeah just kind of okay
anywhere but yes especially school but
but I think I think if we the schools
were one of the first to uh according to
the timeline were affected by all of
this so I think uh and I would be
interested to know which schools have um
taken advantage of the dollars that
they've received to put in air
filtration systems and which have not I
think that uh would be very telling um
so uh is there a a representative um
beler just printed out um
some of the executive orders um to go
over uh that you can take a look at that
came out in a timely fashion so that
they can kind of be seen along with uh
the timeline for
DHHS so uh
we'll all
share I have
six oh this is four oh yeah I have okay
okay take all right yeah we can do that
after if you want well no you might have
questions this isn't this isn't nearly
all there's over a 100 emergency and
executive just yeah so there's six of
there uh if you can pass six one of
these down to uh represent cratan that'd
be
great four right
here's
five four
there
eight one two
there well we're Lear we're learning how
to
count I'm doing four six eight they
didn't coate them first eight or
10 here you go okay
do you all have five down there I have
we already have five over
here
okay four five six I already have all
these that's
right
nine
okay four we already have
four
four were both those gentlemen from the
new hampire Hospital Association I'm not
sure they did not introduce
themselves four why does this four look
different than that
four it's it might be an emergency
versus because it's not the same thing
it's an emergency order not an executive
order oh
my very confusing got to put them in two
buckets
okay okay one two
there
addiction are we looking at is that part
of our scope is looking
at it's so hold on I'll will read you
just so you have a better
I okay
let me just get in
there so it say this is what we're
basically looking at it says that the
areas of focus will include the
administration of federal guidance
acceptance of federal funds and
implementation of the emergency use
authorization vaccination efforts so I
don't
no was that
simple
Madam chair if I may you may
representative beler thank you very much
um so I what I've handed out I've I've
we couldn't possibly in the short notice
print all of them there's over 150 uh
PDF files of orders what I did was I
selected the sort of initial period of
executive orders so executive orders
going I believe roughly through July or
August of 2020 to get a sort of the
flavor of what we're looking at in terms
of what the executive orders were at
that time and also a selection of the
emergency orders um that seem to be
things that would be somewhat of
interest to the committee even if only
tangentially and just to speak to the
issue of the evictions it's it's clearly
not a strictly medical item but as the
covid-19 response efficacy committee I
think we have a little bit of perview to
look at all covid-19 responses
especially since this particular
guidance I know came from the
CDC so it was it was within that sort of
Realm I don't know that we need to get
deep into the economic issues but it's
sort of a tangential topic that we can
it it puts the whole picture together
and I appreciate that I mean I have uh
the de Department of Employment Security
is of also of interest to me because at
the time I was getting three to four
fraudulent uh applicants a
week
um and I you know there was a lot of
fraud trying to be committed I believe I
caught all of them but um I had to go
digging through records five and six
years back um which really put a burden
on businesses so that is I mean if we
have time to look into those other
things I think they're important um and
they could probably be of use that
guidance could be of use in a report
um to maybe uh talk about those things
and how when we do a blanket approach on
something that uh it can have adverse
effects um representative beler thank
you I just one more thing I forgot to
mention when it came to the the eviction
moratorium that was CDC guidance uh that
because there's been some time now since
these things occurred that went all the
way to the Supreme Court and was in fact
ruled illegal by the Supreme
Court well I I thank you for that
information and and thank you for
letting us know about the Supreme Court
decision
um so I mean you know and right here on
this executive order
2020-4 it says s whereas beginning in
December
2019 um you know it starts immediately
uh and that kind of follows through um
you know the
timeline that um Miss Tilly printed out
for us um so we can look at these
executive orders in C be and you know
what I thought was great with the
timeline just is the color coding for me
um because you know if it was a national
event or a dhh event or a state
government event I think that was is
really important um to note because it
looks like sometimes they overlap um and
uh so you can see where there's a lot of
overlapping um and I think if we want to
look at the executive orders and how
they Define the you know the draft um
that is good information
uh Mi uh Miss Tilly uh represent Penza
has another question if you wouldn't
mind I'm not sure uh does it pertain to
the
timeline
okay thank you so in the timeline you
had mentioned um you were talking about
deaths and things like that so um so
this came out in there was a a lot of us
that were really looking at this closely
um so it came out December 28th in 2020
and um so it was one statistic of course
that came from covid-19 this was in the
union leader so 80% of New Hampshire
covid-19 deaths four of every five had
maed residents of long-term care
facilities according to state and
federal data that percentage is twice
the national national average so in
state-by-state color-coded maps the P
nursing home desk New Hampshire was
pronounced um as like number one uh okay
yes leading so in 2020 early in 2020 yes
well or 2020 yeah um it was actually at
the end of 2020 when this early in the
pandemic is what I should have said
okay2 um I'm just I want to understand
because per capita based you know we
were the leading in regards with nursing
homes so I don't want to Pat ourselves
on the back in in regards with that so
what about if you look at those ner the
the data for 3,300 deaths is that just
an overall death rate or is that is that
are you doing it based upon per capita
with population the the 3,300 is the
number so it's not a rate it's just the
raw number of deaths and so we break
that down by ages um I'm not sure that
we break it down by long-term care
facilities anymore we could look at that
I'm actually not clear about that one of
the things I will note about that
proportion because it was a rate it was
a proportion um we didn't experience
deaths in other places so we had deaths
the deaths were in the long-term care
facilities other states experienced many
more deaths among adults that were not
in long-term care we had fewer deaths
outside of long-term care so that that's
part of what makes that data point um
complex and and and represent penzer I
think that once she's going to do a
breakdown for us by age I think that
will give us a good picture
of um what is going on because we're
going to get the age you know the 3,300
deaths I mean I want to know how many
young kids are part of that 3,300 how
many in their 20s um I mean I think it's
important to have those numbers um by by
age population and I believe Miss Tilly
said that uh she would uh provide that
to the committee yes that's that's
easily available and those proportions
shifted over time too so again 2020
early in the pandemic the deaths were by
far were in long-term care facilities we
didn't have as many deaths among adults
that were not in long-term care
facilities as other states had we can
maybe recall um news images of like New
York City where you know the hospitals
were just filled with people in the
hallways that were dying we did not
experience that early in the pandemic
our greatest area and and again I want
to completely underscore those deaths
are important in the long-term care I
don't want to have anyone think that
we're being dismisses of them those were
important deaths those were important
people to people's families but that's
what we saw in the
beginning thank you um
so on that note and I know this I'm not
positive if this was a you know we
talked about CMS guidelines and things
like that um and CDC guidelines in Long
term care
facilities but my question would be
um because we were locking things down
and as we
know anytime kids return back to school
and you put them all it's like a petri
dish right um so is there anything that
could have been done differently to help
prevent the spread in nursing homes
because you may have one to four people
in a room and what would be interesting
and I don't know and I'm sure that this
data would be like really hard to get
is how in a nursing home was it all the
same people in a unit were they in
separate units I mean that would be
really interesting data I know it would
probably be difficult to have but that I
think that data would be really tell
on how the spread happened in nursing
homes um so sure you know what I would
suggest to that um two things one um the
Department of Health and Human Services
our division of Public Health still
works with long-term care facilities
when they have outbreaks again
individual reports of covid-19
individual cases are no longer reported
to us but if there's an outbreak that is
reported to the department and so they
still continue to this day in long-term
care facilities and other congregate
living facilities not to the degree that
it was but it it hasn't gone away um I
think what you're asking for um I'm not
aware of a you know a uh evidence-based
um scientific journal article on it that
may exist that's just not off the top of
my head I can't recall one but I am sure
that there are individuals in the state
with the lived experience in
administering those those nursing homes
who can talk to you about what that was
like and what they experienced um during
that time we also at the division of
Public Health probably have some broad
Strokes that we could say about in when
investigating those outbreaks what our
broad observations were again we don't
have a detailed report ready to go that
gives you definitive numbers but there's
certainly some observations that can be
drawn after looking at those um uh
outbreaks over time and also the
infection control policies that were put
in place you know everything from air
filtration you know to your point
earlier to the mechanics of how do you
make sure not only for covid but you
just simply work on infection um control
that's that's part and parcel of the
work of Public Health we do that for
covid we do that for everything
else represent
Penza so that's one area that um just
because of my husband I'm uh become kind
of an expert in uh is the air filtration
um my husband's in that space um so I
don't understand why and maybe you'll
know that information and this might be
a question for another time that should
have been the number one thing that we
did as a state in every single facility
hospital long-term care school um there
are tons of studies that talk about um
full fresh air coming in filtration
systems and literally zero cases of
covid I can I can give you every bit of
that data and I would love to know every
dime nickel and Penny that has been
spent in New Hampshire on that I think
think that's the one thing we get all of
this Federal money in and that should
have been the first thing that we were
doing in all the County nursing homes
and all of that with the covid money and
in you know in some schools in straford
County where I'm a rep and you can tell
I'm a little heated about this because
it bothers me instead of taking the
money and using it for things like this
we built a new roof and so you know in
the essence of if we're talking about
public health this is the number one
thing that we've known for
decades and you know this because you're
in this space right so so yeah so I'm
glad you asked it uh it's a you know
there was a lot of people that were
talking about it here too meaning like
we got some old buildings here and stuff
like that you know I know there's one
over here but that it is why we have air
filters and it's hard for those of us
who can't hear because now we have white
noise machines everywhere exactly um you
know I I I will just underscore that
certainly air filtration and air
handling um was part of the conversation
early on and um to your question about
funding this is the no pun intended the
million doll question because there were
lots of different lines of federal
funding schools received their funds
directly or through the Department of
Education was not um and you know we
believe in local control in the state so
there are places where they made their
own decisions about what to do with some
of those resources it just it completely
it bypassed in a sense bypassed the
state it went direct so you're exactly
right thank you um and I I think that
everyone on this commi committee would
agree that air filtration is extremely
important and maybe part of the guidance
and in future would be figuring out what
the number one number two uh criteria to
help prevent illnesses and spreads like
air filtration and if they're receiving
money make that a
mandate um I hate the word mandate uh
just so you understand
um
but mandating that a public facility has
air good air filtration is good public
policy um and so I think uh this is a
good topic and I think uh this C you
know just having that out there and
letting the public know that this is how
dollars should dollars shouldn't be
spent when you get guidance on new
things they should be concentrating on
the health of the the public
first
um so uh but I don't know if the report
that's coming out will discuss things
like that um but your
thoughts I have a lot of thoughts um I'm
not sure that our after action will will
dive into that I don't know that again
director buckton is much more involved
in it than I am on that um you know I
can tell you from my experience sitting
on the governor's economic reopening
task force that as we talked with
Industries reopening that air
circulation and air filtration was a
conversation that was had on many of
those calls for different types of
settings um and again those those calls
were really about the econom you know
the um economic reopening of businesses
and Industry not schools we did not
address schools in that particular realm
there were weekly calls with the
Department of Health and Human Services
schools to answer their questions just
again to provide support to nurses so
they were not left out but they had
their own way much in the same way that
there were calls with Healthcare
Providers every week um to again elicit
questions from the community and for us
to provide some resources and support
where we could but again the one of the
lessons of covid-19 and otherwise is air
air handling is important and so we we
looked to you know oosha regulations and
there are all sorts of other sort of
mechanical things that you can do to
support that represent
pit thank you Madame chair uh it's more
a comment than a question but uh I agree
that a quality is important but uh I
think we need some data to Scientific
data to tell us like how much uh it
helps and also like there are two
strategies uh uh and um again like
between science and other kinds of
decisions but one
strategy uh was to try to delay new
cases in order to give more times to
develop
treatment but another strategy would be
to identify for example if if uh school
age kids are
not vulnerable are not dying from Co in
New Hampshire maybe it would makes
sense the reverse approach to let covid
go through and let them quickly get
immunity and through that natural
immunity protect uh eventually those
vulnerable and be done with pandemic at
least in schools so there are also like
this approach like uh what is the cost
of delaying this new cases uh and maybe
we
shouldn't
representative leus do you have a
question well I had a I've been making a
a little list of the things that we've
been coming up with um evolution of
testing hospitals schools air quality
nursing
homes I you
know what do I do with this list do we
have other people other things that we
should put on this list
Etc you know as we discussed early th
this topic is so broad but we have a
finite amount of time to do things um so
we're going to have to tackle
things um one at a
time
um and we H we're going to have to kind
of look at uh what is
glaring and what is most important to
this committee obviously air quality is
important um but I would like to uh
speak to the gentleman real quick from
the New Hampshire Hospital Association
if I could just ask you a quick
question oh I don't want you to
testify um but yes okay I will talk to
you
offline um but I will just say this I
think that maybe just so you understand
where I'm coming from that having some
understanding of how the policies at
hospital were instituted uh would be
extremely helpful for this committee um
I would like to get everyone's thoughts
on that on what they
think I think um having a hospital day
would be a good idea um
having both the gentlemen here and
potentially you know some of our
somebody from some of our major
hospitals in the state because I think
we had some differences between how
different hospitals handle some
things I don't know I mean but having a
day that we've said okay today's
Hospital day like today was timeline day
right right and and I think included in
that could be uh nursing homes um
because they kind of go hand inand a
little bit um public and County um so I
think it's important to understand I
mean I know the struggles that my County
had um obviously during covid um and I'm
sure that every other County encountered
some of the same things and some of the
guidance that came down how it affected
them um
and what I guess the the bigger question
was is what could the state have done
to mitigate some of those mandates to
make it easier for our County nursing
homes to operate and take care of the
patients um any thoughts on
that is everyone in agreement of that
okay perfect um any other specific
topics I I think uh having you know so
so far what I've heard is we want to
have basically a health day basic I'm
going to call it a health day with
hospitals and nursing homes um a day of
on
education um
and we're going to have uh I got to
reach back out to director buckton but
he is here available the last uh Friday
in March um and that would basically
it is so that would take care of the
three Fridays in March that we are
currently scheduling the meetings we we
scheduling one for March 8th March 15th
and March 29th March 29th will
definitely be in the morning at 9:00
a.m. um because that is when the
director is available the other two I
will send out an email to see if to the
group to see morning or afternoon on the
8th and the 15th what works best for
everyone do we
know do we know what who we want you
know what days those what I we're going
to bring in those days I will reach out
to the the the people and see who is
available on which day and that will be
determined um I can't speak I I don't
have their schedules and uh they would
have to let me know their
availability does that work for
everyone okay if is there any further
discussion that we need here this
morning okay I'll just say in terms of
scheduling um I would be also okay with
if we did maybe like one day but longer
um might be easier than everyone getting
here like every Friday morning maybe a
little bit well I I think I don't know I
I I think once you know the organization
day was pretty short this one but I
think once we start getting into if we
do a health day I think I think that's
going to take a little bit longer and
education day we'll be looking at a lot
of different uh factors I mean we could
be looking at you know things like uh
special ed needs how they compared
before the pandemic how they compared
after you know things like that we could
even bring talk about the air filtration
in the schools and the guidance on that
so there's a lot of things that can go
into those topics so I think those days
will be longer but I think we needed to
have a timeline and really start asking
the questions to see which way we wanted
to go representative
beler thank you madam chair I I I tend
to agree with that and I would just add
that even though today has been a bit of
a shorter
day this day at least for me and I
suspect some of the other us is going to
drive hours of further work putting
together research putting together
questions those questions will be then
forwarded on to the appropriate parties
who will then drive the continuation of
this committee forward so I I would
think it would be necessary um or at
least advisable to continue to meet on
roughly a weekly basis thank you uh
representative Bel I understand uh that
but right now next week uh we are all on
vacation um so March
8th well when I say vacation I'm saying
from
session uh most of us aren on vacation
um but if there are any questions for
any of the Departments I would ask that
everyone please send them to me and I
will forward them so that they're not
getting multiple emails from people um
so that we can streamline the process uh
and and it won't be so
overwhelming is there anything
else if there's nothing else uh I'd like
to thank everyone for driving here in
the snow this morning it was a little
bit uh messy and uh slow goinging that's
nice out but I wish everyone a wonderful
weekend and uh if you're so lucky to go
on vacation next week have a great time
and I'll will call this meeting
adjourned thank
you